- I was like, oh shoot, you
know I'm gonna do this video
so I tried to do like some
eight-minute abs (laughs).
And I did them again this morning.
(drums playing)
- I feel like I should've been working out
for the past six months.
- A lot of people see
me and they think that,
oh, he's this thin guy,
he's not secure with the way he looks,
but I think everyone is insecure.
- I struggle with a lot
of body confidence issues.
- I'm not incredibly proud of my body.
I think I have an okay body.
- Going into this, I'm hoping to gain
a new perspective on clothing and style.
- I'm coming into this very, just like,
more on the uncomfortable
end, and hoping that
I break out of that shell
and just own this crop top.
- I want to showcase my body
and not be ashamed of it.
- Oh my God, this is
like wearing a toothpick.
- Not mad at it.
- Hey, Maggie.
- Hey, what's up?
- Oh my God.
(laughs)
- At the beginning of the day,
I was so so uncomfortable.
- The computer blocks our view.
I wasn't prepared to see that.
- I've just never seen you this way.
- And your boxers above your
jeans is making me laugh
cuz it's like the boy
version of a whale tail,
when a girl has the thong sticking out.
- When you walked up to me,
I literally pulled this down cuz I thought
you just had your shirt tied up.
But you look great.
- (chuckles) Oh, you did a crop top.
- Wearing a crop top for a day
was really uncomfortable for me.
I feel self-conscious.
- Same.
Uggh!
Lot of flexing.
- We just got our lunch
and we were waiting for probably
a good five or ten minutes
and it just really felt
awkward the whole time.
- I'm an introvert.
So I don't like being the person
that everybody is staring at.
- So apparantley I've been
wearing crop tops wrong.
I got advice from one
of the TopKnot girls.
You're supposed to wear
high-waisted pants,
or have something tied around you.
- Alright, Crystal is teaching me
the proper way to sit
when you're wearing a crop top.
- You gotta perch on the end.
Put your feet out.
Chest out.
Belly flat.
- So it's the middle of the day
and I just went to The Canteen,
and there were some co-workers there.
None of them said anything,
so I guess it might be more acceptable
to wear this than I really think it is.
- And then as you go throughout the day,
it's kinda like, "Well,
whatever. Everybody's staring
so might as well give 'em
something to look at, right?"
(cheers)
- So as the day is progressing,
I'm getting much more confident .
- A little happy trail going.
It's nice.
- A happy trail,
nice chest hair.
- We see it all.
- Sex. Just a lot of sex.
- This is like one of the hottest days
we've had in a while.
- Sexy.
Ow Ow baby!
Gimme a piece of that.
(chuckles)
- feeling less awkward.
- Own it.
Looks so good on you.
- I love this little ab line right here.
- Oh, thanks girl.
- Wearing a crop top
definitely made me more insecure
about my own body.
I think we all are our own worst critic.
- I still got a lotta weird looks.
Like, "Why is that guy's
belly all up everywhere?"
- That being said,
this article of clothing was
the most comfortable thing
I've worn in a very long time.
- By the end of the day,
I had accepted myself
and it didn't matter
what people were saying
because I felt secure in my body.
- [Voiceover] Down the line,
I think I wouldn't mind
trying it out again.
But probably not anytime soon.